you
when a charger do you feel 50 when I see
all the refugees arriving in Germany
today donate it reminds me of when we
fled from Poland to the west when I was
a child I did nothing wrong our children
didn't support the regime for the
revolution we lived in the heart of
Damascus our house was destroyed sarsen
there were so many massacres I lived in
constant fear you lost track of who was
killing whom you lose sight of the truth
die as religion sook one Suzie when the
train arrived at the friedland transit
camp in 1947 it marked the beginning of
a new life for me that's why friedland
is almost like a birthplace to me I'm
the boards on
ah tomorrow Cuba too much it has a photo
delish if I suppose where that V has do
yes I said maniana go to mark in Miami
rhenish Hoyden friedland when I me
children in Friedland today whether they
come from Syria Lebanon or wherever I
see myself in them then I have to ask
myself if these little girls these
little six or seven year olds will ever
get a chance as i was given once you've
been uprooted is it possible to put down
new roots and what can we the ones who
managed it do for these people so that
they succeed to the shaft on this is
clapping come dear Mark Thomas do former
here wasn't your trailer
precisely buddhist conceivably ish comma
of Roseland I come from Russia climbed
off go wouldn't I grew up in a
german-speaking village fergie mentioned
goleta p.m. we spoke a german dialect at
home this was on a client there was a
small German community wouldn't ya want
to minor Elton army and my parents
always dreamt about moving to Germany
one day nach deutschland seen as I
chopped us but it wasn't something that
I ever really thought about the room you
kinda get doesn't go mouth I was happy
in content in Russia but in 1991 my
parents decided to move here once a
specialist in when the Elton here nach
deutschland Soutine it's pretty material
that is for the Magica Majid East is
nisht mr. March it is mr. who's to music
a little Latin Latin
hello hello hello hello that's too that
is me happen on dish faced Sandy Weill
as a dequindre blame me about one sting
from the children only stay with us for
five days that's not very long but even
in those five days we can see how much
they change parents have shown us
drawings their children made of masked
men with weapons and they told us how
much that upset them warrenton angst ina
formula that's one family said they
still never get undressed because they
think it's still like in Syria and they
could be bombed at any minute so langsam
but slowly they start to live normal
lives again and at some point the
children start to draw happier pictures
with flowers or something cheerful not
so shocking be sent via MIDI been done
any Suresh second game yeah yeah damas I
know noise in 1991 I thought I would
never come back to friedland so being
shocked those seven days were such a
shock to my system I don't think I
understood anything that was going on in
my corpse I always had a headache I had
to figure things out and couldn't really
grasp how different everything was here
vista's here the siskins and us um its
quantity to begin with even though I
could speak German I couldn't understand
anyone the first a sneak I'll authority
to cancel I think that happens that you
don't understand anything anymore alice
is more it's so unfamiliar like losing
your way in a forest you're completely
disoriented
Venice will mention Z when I see people
arriving here I have a sense that they
also have headaches just like I did I
know how they feel they feel the way I
did back then daddy getsuga be hope now
that all my sanity i'm so restless I
can't sleep I just want to find
somewhere quiet to be with my children I
can't ever go back to Afghanistan as i
left my first husband without getting
divorced in Afghanistan the punishment
for that is stony man wad up once on you
know me I'm San sorry haha I was forced
to marry when I was 15 as I did there
was a huge age difference 35 years
that's why I left well CC will pine
Cypress cherish my dads were later I met
my second husband he's the father of my
children I married him in secret that's
why we fled to Europe the hotter and
more pie okay my name will pop Norwood
Young tagging a man my CC when I lived
in Norway for three years shall we kill
one night the police came to our door it
was three or four in the morning we were
asleep it was a shock especially for me
and my eldest daughter the police told
us we had 10 minutes to get ready to
leave my [ __ ] until the minute that they
came and took us we couldn't really
believe what was happening but waking
one of my fan but they are a thong when
we were sitting in the plane back to
Afghanistan I fell apart damn
han son Colin Ford Rodman my first
husband is very powerful he would have
been able to find me anywhere in
Afghanistan I was in a terrible state I
was convinced that my life and the lives
of my family were in danger we were
afraid to leave the house I could have
been spotted by relatives of my first
husband was botulinum madam Mina the
charm that would care I fled afghanistan
again with my second husband he's still
in Turkey
holla holla Homewood my children and I
were given a very warm welcome here
palanca my strength is returning I feel
optimistic I hope we'll be able to stay
what kind of money you didn't ago
no that's mine that was 69 years ago we
were in those corrugated steel huts over
there I remember how we would sit on the
bed it was all such a novel experience
but we all sat on those bunk beds
together your idols hello
no this is only Zeb it's very moving to
see it all again but times have changed
this became my area of expertise I was a
university professor friedland has a
very good reputation as a refugee camp
which is partly thanks to people like
you
if endure that's what droid Galaga I
love the term transit camp well it
spells out that life for Refugees is
about moving on fulfilling her you might
enjoy come to your closest a transit
camp should be a place of security amid
the chaos of fleeing the drama of what
you've experienced that was certainly
how I felt and Colitis face a buffer
zone where you can gather your thoughts
and think about where you want to go
where you're allowed to go over and
consoles I'm William ah it's a place
where someone gives you something to eat
a bed to sleep in a roof over your head
mindful helps you sort out your papers
and everything you need in order to move
on
my name is Johanna higher I'm a carrot s
counselor I'm sure you all have lots of
questions about your children who are
still in Lebanon get into a coma at my
seed evansville ethically satin bloom
nine or more ojala and it's about my
daughter she's married and lives in
Jordan she spent two days waiting on the
border to get back in two days we want
her to come here she wasn't allowed to
re-enter the country that's a time what
if she had to go back to Damascus she
wanted to say goodbye to us all before
we left she came on her own an officer
promised her she'd be able to enter the
country again in a week's time Aziz her
daughter flew from Jordan to Lebanon to
say goodbye and now they won't let her
back in was he'd obviously stood Chilean
and bi yo I can understand that you're
very worried about your daughter you
don't know what's going on and you're
concerned that she's on her own in a
complicated situation I'm shaman home
okie Annie Masonic indeed it was addict
scientific arena he knows I honey yeah
we'll listen she that she says it might
be her fault she just wanted to say
goodbye and now her daughter can't go
home
I heard a bit more about Lily Hanuman I
just want my family to be together and
lead a normal life that's all I want a
place where we can be safe somewhere to
live I want our children to get an
education we want them to go to school
thank God I'm still strong enough to
work I hope our children have an
opportunity to go to school they've lost
so many years money does your name I
hope that my eldest son can come here
with his wife he was less fortunate than
we were I hope he can get here I knew
when my wife thinks of our eldest son
she cries all night I hope we can get
help in bringing him here he wasn't one
of the lucky ones yeah I'm long and then
we only just arrived in Germany so far
everything we've seen has been wonderful
yeah Oh chef let's go see alumina
couldn't him I'm a little Amy anybody we
were given was very kind warm welcome my
son some bad everyone says good morning
to us any everyone smiles at us no no
one who looks as though they resent us
you know with hawk or know anybody
people smiling at this makes us feel
welcome
you
you
as a dimension lenient written the
people who arrived in Friedland have
fled conflicts harder it's shocking to
see the faces of refugees coming from
places like eritrea young people young
men young women traveling alone they
have long journeys behind them they've
made their way here across the African
continent and cross the Mediterranean
from northern Africa the trip is
dangerous and they're probably tied up
with shady people smugglers who they are
forced to rely on in their bid to apply
for asylum in Germany you can't make an
application from outside Europe you have
to enter Europe illegally there's no way
to apply for asylum from outside Europe
oomphel from outside as you to run time
you gotta barakatuh lemon garden where
did you stay in Libya when you were
travelling on your own see I stayed at a
farm in Abu Salim were a lot of other
people from Eritrea and Somalia were
living people from Nigeria and Ghana to
one day I got a job a man showed up and
told me I could clean his mother's house
for 50 Dean are a day she didn't feel my
only day wish it I went with him we
drove a long way and at some point I
didn't know where we were anymore we
were no longer on the main road Murphy
it restored there were only two black
men there no mother the man who driven
me there was white so there were three
men obviously Laguna tlie to light
another I didn't they told me to take
off my clothes I told them I was there
to work that I didn't need to take off
my clothes to work then one of them hit
me that's road yet and I cried but no
one could hear me daddy one of the dark
skinned men kept hitting me he beat me
senseless again I took my head scarf to
cover myself up they said to me don't
act as though you were a woman
you're nothing your death would mean
nothing Oh vintage analogous a little
ana matically I'll again then they took
my headscarf and used it to tie my hands
together so I couldn't feel anything
anymore were you unconscious they
blindfolded me and I was powerless there
were three of them I lost track of time
I don't know if I regained consciousness
that day or the next a young battery
like my bad virginie hello then they
took me to another farm with African
refugees it wasn't the same one I'd been
at before they left me lying outside it
I don't know how long I was there then
people found me they put me in a room
but no one dared touch me for months I
didn't know what was going on around me
dad come Joe Maddon later I realized I
was pregnant not a bad day Sheila [ __ ]
can see hush all the refugees they
wanted to get away to Europe has a
definite Ellen I should know was he Sims
I gave all my savings to people
smugglers I didn't they took us to Italy
then I paid more smugglers to take me to
Germany I'm an efficient again the other
refugees knew that I didn't have any
money left I should
tell him but they helped me they
collected money for me hello wish I
didn't sit there are still good people
in the world lakin bazzill was a lot of
good her name's your gate defective
lemon when I was in such a bad state I
just wanted to die I could only think
about the problems but then I began to
hope things would get better nothing
will happen to you here in Germany
you're safe no one can hurt you he's a
circle egg easy I will raise this child
it was a traumatic experience but it's
not the child's fault will you be able
to love the child I hope so
beginning and fighter because Cena thank
you haga lo han mal still in GD fogger
15 15 15 yeah Johnny feel the noize ish
cousin so nine ish lip on the airport
since the 90 keyboard cluster warranty
no kind man
no magical no money i wanna who and i
always thought germany was a beautiful
country I love to watch German football
I'm crazy about it I always want germany
to win go germany I've had the
goalkeeper pulls a face like a tiger
when he dives for the ball just like a
tiger holly's rural areas oh I really
like Germany I never dared dream I'd
come here one day noise y'all on money
you
you
let the dogs in Syria they bite they're
not pets and honestly not very nice no
they're not nice and they're dirty I'm
afraid of them here we've seen dogs with
special hairdos people here bade their
dogs and take them to the doctor we
don't do that this is a lovely country
the people are nice we had fun on
today's outing
poor amalapuram all aboard Friedland is
a very peaceful place I've been here 22
days and have been very happy I did
transfer data loggers I just cut my
transfer papers the google ad I'm being
moved tomorrow I'm a bit worried about
what will happen next hello me I hope
I'll be granted asylum here [ __ ]
doodle 2 Z 3 when I talk to the other
refugees here in a friedland about how
they were persecuted and the
difficulties they've had feel that my
own problems are relatively minor in
comparison everyone has a story to tell
every story is full of suffering and
sorrow distorted the bell go 30 m Hey
look part of your other fish I insist hi
and I
why hi there Michigan's like it
EXT I'm now going to tell you the places
you're being sent I wasn't the one who
chose them they were decided by
representatives in the states where
you'll be going let's start with jebao
you're going to visa let me show you
where it is on the map its east of my
rights by Reuters the nearest big city
you'll be leaving tomorrow at eight in
the morning all the other families are
being sent to a town called Brighton
brun in Saxony it's south of the city of
kemnitz abdelaziz all who sorry Cano's
all hobble
how do you have a future tomorrow you'll
go to oldenburg me yes I'm fine tomorrow
you go have a breakfast and then yes the
bus will come and you will say bye-bye
sweetland now I go again feeling ok yeah
we go back all the best for you and
thanks a lot Valhalla I don't know Luxy
we've heard it some people in Saxony
don't like Arabs and that we'd be better
off someplace else the island I don't
know but a friend of mine told me that
Saxony is lovely and then I shouldn't
listen to the others what this moment
he's been here for 27 years the onion
sauce believe me Germans are the same
all over the country they all treat you
the saddle I wouldn't allow any be put
off he said layer up the lemon knows I
know habana me nerdy hello people say
all sorts of things I'm gonna send me
we're gonna say theme yeah maybe people
in Saxony are the nicest we hope so it
amini religions are no different from
people here I've eaten of solanum I'm
sure they're the same forgiveness alone
oh and a talk yesterday we heard that
article 1 of German basic law says that
human dignity is inviolable well that's
why I can't believe that if it says that
in the Constitution that people will
treat others badly I can't imagine that
it was good to hear people come before
all owls
then some [ __ ] she
the sign a hungry
Oh
even your sisters and brothers hi any
cuz its many of you are looking forward
to tomorrow you've learned that you'll
be transferred to Saxony button
rutenberg Bavarian Priscilla Byron
mithani a season cuz you're probably
wondering what awaits you there that's a
hot deja after da city should have good
muscle to him well then where we live
where will your children go to school
Medeiros that animal you got--that's
will you get a job will you learn the
language big bath with nice a terpolymer
looga savannah and you'll meet people
who will show you the same kindness that
you've experienced in friedland to be
profitable there aha a joke on guna
mental map into honey you feelin he'll
do it from the hook Holly Ollis on
Korea's electoral to be a marine who's
even mentioned but you might also make
people who are less kind there are
people in Germany who are afraid of
foreigners who stir up anger against you
and your friends yellow fondant pumpkin
and to talk with us motley well I'm it
go Tina's kamat Yanukovych on Ava's left
is a joke it's not funny it will be an
exciting time for you you're heading
into the future but looking back at the
past because of course your hearts and
minds are still in your homelands and
with the people who can't be here beside
you I'm not even to ask arto gusto
miliani with turkey a free bottle mine
wounds but I wish for you is that you
can follow your path in peace and safety
these are height community college even
Allah elkin Babu maracas request a good
a shoe bacela
the aleve me has been known to happen
that people leave friedland at eight in
the morning but then call us at five in
the afternoon from schleswig-holstein or
saxony saying please come and get us
because the accommodation they've been
given is inhumane that does happen the
speci it saxon the spoons and hectus
luckily the way it's done in saxony is
that everyone is housed together in one
place in holiday homes or guest houses
Manuela took a little over with kitchens
ngayon alam of course is there all
self-contained units Sammy Amira exact
as many have told us that they have
family members coming on the next flight
and we've passed that on I know that
family is very important in your
cultures and that naturally you want to
be together and we can always strive for
this in the long term list in my husband
and look there's no need to worry yet
it's never rained like this before
someone must be very sad that you're all
going we're crying too for our people
our homes and you're all really good
friends even though you've only just got
to know each other but here you do bond
somehow you're not alone look everyone's
going with you I hope I'll see my
children again that they can join me you
know we like feel really I hope you get
everything you wish for two I hope
things go well for you let's hope
hello fellow said him shining celebi I'm
we're making fun of poor Ahmed he hasn't
slept since yesterday when we arrived in
friedland he fell in love with her
straight away the last thing you said to
me look at that girl no ha I told him
she is beautiful but she is Christian I
wouldn't anybody he only had eyes for
her haha wait have you fell in love with
her and she fell in love with him what
this one and then it started with
whatsapp what's what's what's are you
sad that she's going to a different
state of course do you want to marry her
would that be possible hey anything is
possible everyone is equal can you read
my future a social thing sure you'll see
drink up your coffee first I said I will
you always love her like a tempeh for
all eternity oh really yeah yes really
as his father I welcome the idea
I'd be happy for him no she's a good
person no I've you holla holla Texas
something will happen there might be
problems I'm ready for them double our
winner do you see it take a look Pablo
listen how does it end Vanessa the end
looks all white I love ya I don't know
only God knows but I some good signs
for meetings friedland Nicola Wiggins
ines mom I see Friedland land of peace
as a metaphor and not just because of
the name it has a message that we have
to be a land of peace one that takes in
people fleeing very different perilous
situations and treats them humanely I
think friedland has a very important
function to make Germans realize you
were at war once too and you were taking
on your old man a goofy and I think this
is the big lesson that anyone from one
moment to the next can lose even the
ground beneath their feet and there is
no greater harm one can inflict on
humanity than to close the door on
people the tall edema
you
you